In the 1980s,
Richard Grinold was seeking a method of
relating performance, skill,
and breadth in investing.
So for instance,
you might be a very skilled investor,
meaning that you can pick stocks well,
but
you might not have many opportunities or
breadth to exercise that skill.
So Grinold felt that there must
be some equation whereby we could
combine skill and breadth to
create an estimate of performance.
He developed a relationship he called
the Fundamental Law of
Active Portfolio Management.
I'm going to state it here at the
beginning of the lesson, and then spend
the rest of the lesson trying to justify
it and show you why it makes sense.
And here's his expression,
performance is equal to skill
times the square root of breadth.
So we need some measure of skill and
some measure of breadth.
So if you want to improve your
performance you can improve skill, or
you can find more and
more applications or methods or
opportunities for applying that skill.
So, as an example breadth might relate
to how many stocks you invest in and
skill relates to your
skill in choosing them.
So, again you can invest in
either improving your skill or
improving your breadth.
So performance is summarized in
something called information ratio,
which is very much like the sharpe
ratio that we've discussed before, but
it refers to the sharpe ratio of excess
returns, in other words the manner
in which the portfolio manager is
exceeding the market's performance.
Skill is summarized in something
called Information coefficient and
and breadth is just how many
trading opportunities we have.
Okay.
So,
we'll expand more and more on
this as we go through the lesson.